when you're developing a new impression
do you lock yourself in a room and like
do it over and over and over again I can
do do you but it my impression of you
they might around the area yeah now like
this like look at you look at what
you've done
Wow we said as we've said it all we've
said all Robbie your Seinfeld is [ __ ]
great if you did the whole Tonight Show
like that I would watch the whole
episode you do a good Chris Rock too you
do a great Chris Rock I still walk
through Central Park and just keep
listening to his act over and over again
and just impersonating like kind of
screaming I was crazy so you would walk
around with your headset on let's say
you're walking around outside and you're
you're not listening to Chris Rock for
enjoyment at that point you're listening
to get down the voice right it becomes
important to you so it's not enjoyment
it's just work impression was the one
that got me sent live that audition I
did him before anyone was doing Sandler
and he just left the show so when I did
his impression Lauren started laughing
with Ben Stiller was interesting he came
on to host and he goes you gotta have
this kid do Adam Sandler yeah we know he
does a sandwich but you know he's brand
new let's come sometime Ben's like no
let's do it now so then Lauren said well
with call and make sure he's cool with
it so we called Sandler he goes alright
it do it for me and I go hey we like you
know whatever and he goes alright that's
pretty good you can do it good luck good
luck good luck and so I ended up doing
if Adams writing partner Jim Hurley it
was still on SNL and so he was laughing
because he was like yeah Sandler would
kind of do something that Kalika tells
it's got to be very specific right you
can't just read a sketch and sound like
Adam Sandler it has to be a certain kind
of line I would try to remember like
some line or something that he does like
he does the mumbling voice then he does
the like the kind of stupid voice and
then he does the screaming
so it's the monthly noise it's just kind
of like I yeah I know you doing I was
ringing the doorbell and I said they
grandma it's me it's a tree branch and
she said who child NASA not Charles
Manson Adam you grant stuff like that
you